¿Qué pasa, pizarritas? Ya estamos aquí un viernes más para responder vuestras sabias e interesantes cuestiones que nos dejasteis el otro día en Twitter.
Adrián Blanco, Alex de Llano, Nahuel Miranda, ¿cómo estáis?
¿Qué tal, chicos? Muy buenas. ¿Cómo andamos?
¿Qué tal? Muy buenas. No quiero hacer de menos la camiseta de Nahuel Miranda, pero, hombre, la de Alex y la de Adri...
¿Camisetones, no?
¡Fines!
Mira, Puli, mira, Puli.
¿Qué? Bueno.
Pagan.
Bueno, no pagan.
Ah, ¿sabes?
No, no pagan.
A mí me han pagado por ir a torneos de Pickleball.
¡Ah! Pickleball, eh.
En uno de mis incontables...
Trinques, eh.
Images tuosos. Trinques. Hay que...
El trinque de Karlovic.
Hay que alimentar muchas bocas, entre ellas vuestras tres boquitas.
El caso, hoy, hablando de camisetas...
Pero, pero, si eso trincaste solo tú.
Bueno, pero para que vosotros podáis trincar de otras cosas, yo trinco aquí, ¿sabes?
Para que vosotros podáis ganar, yo gané antes.
Miel, miel.
¿No?
No cuela.
¿Has trincao? ¿Has trincao a tope con trincar?
No me perdones la verdad.
De cara, eh. De cara, hay que ir de cara.
Trincando hay que ir de cara.
Bueno, el caso, hoy vamos a regalar camisetones, incluso mejores que los que tenéis, porque son de Gambea, son personalizados y son para uno de los cuatro siguientes equipos,
que son, básicamente, los que han ganado o al menos que están como candidatos en el sorteo de Gambea.
Los de Gambea se han currado una barbaridad, les hemos pedido un vídeo para dilucidar, para tener más argumentos.
Los cuatro elegidos son Julepe.
Julepe.
Los Chavales del Sella, que estarán, imagino, con tu camiseta, Alex.
Equipete Fútbol Club, que ahora es que han hecho un vídeo muy fino.
Y somos Usera Gout, que directamente son Alfred Kitt, Hit Coach.
¿Cine?
Mira que podrías haber dicho, no sé, Nolan, para asegurar.
Kubrick.
Hit Coach.
Rally Scott, no.
Almas Chungos.
¿Cómo ha llamado hoy al nuevo propietario del Récord de Porto Español?
Alan Pisz.
¡Qué nombre que no!
Hay que confiar en Alan Pisz.
Es cuando en Ion Sowitz se impone un rival, ¿no?
Pisz and Love, ¿no?
¿Lo sabéis?
¿La famosa anécdota esa?
Sí, sí.
No nos ha contado nunca.
Bueno, igual hay que escribir un artículo si acabo el del Boxing Day este año.
El caso, vamos con la primera cuestión de este Q&A y diremos quién es el ganador de
este sorteo con Gambea después de la quinta pregunta, ¿vale?
Vale.
Hoy son 11.
¿11?
Es que son muy buenas.
Y he dicho, no puedo dejar ninguna fuera.
¿Al mismo precio?
¿11 al mismo precio?
En principio sí.
Vale.
Ah, venga.
Aquí trinco yo, no trinquéis vosotros.
Primera, primera cuestión de Tecchio Ryoku No Mao.
Jue.
Ejícice.
Ya va siendo hora de hablar de Martín Zubimendi por delante de Rodri de cara al Mundial.
Este es un tema que yo creía que solo íbamos a tratar aquí, pero que tratamos el otro
día en la pizarra.
No lo tenía en el guión, pero que lo sacó Emilio Contreras en el debate y que tiene
mucho sentido.
Rodri es el balón de oro, el mejor mediocentro del mundo, pero viene de una lesión de cruzado,
está teniendo problemas físicos.
No sabemos cómo va a estar en el Mundial, que da tiempo todavía, margen, pero cabe
la posibilidad y hay unas cuantas.
O sea, cabe un alto porcentaje de posibilidades de que Rodri no llegue ni al 100% ni al 90
al Mundial.
Y ahí es donde entra el nombre de Martín Zubimendi.
Si Rodri no está en perfectas condiciones, este es un debate que hay que plantear, chicos.
A mí es que me parece completamente lógico.
Rodri no completa una temporada de ser titular, de no sentir esas molestias, de no ser capaz
de encadenar su fútbol durante mucho tiempo.
Creo que Martín Zubimendi está ocupando la posición de una manera en la que creo que
lo que menos ha notado la selección española en el último año es que no estuviera Rodri.
A mí me preocupa cero el tema, la verdad.
Plena confianza en Martín Zubimendi, lo demostró en la final de la Eurocopa entrando desde
el banquillo por Rodri, precisamente.
Si Rodri no llega, si Rodri no encadena partidos, si no tiene regularidad física y no está
al 100% de cara al Mundial, Martín Zubimendi, que creo que en el Arsenal está demostrando
lo que ya vimos en la Real Sociedad, que era uno de los mejores midocentros del mundo,
uno de los mejores en su posición.
Así que en este sentido, máxima tranquilidad.
Me preocuparía más, fíjate, si no está Carvajalzano.
Sí es que queda muchísimo, pero por una valoridad.
He hecho el ejercicio de irme a la misma altura de temporada en el año 2023, esto es en la
previa de la Eurocopa, parón de octubre, segundo partido en Noruega-España, ganan en España
0-1, gol de Gabi.
En aquella convocatoria hay nueve futbolistas que no fueron a la Eurocopa, jugó el titular
de Ferran García en el lateral izquierdo, jugó el propio Gabi, jugó Ansu Fátis en la izquierda,
jugó Ferran Torres en la derecha,
en el banquillo, Kepa, David García, Pau Torres, Pedraza, Brian Zaragoza...
Falta una barbaridad.
Pero ahí estaba empezando el ciclo.
Claro, claro.
Ahora ya no.
No, no.
No hubo tantos cambios en la convocatoria.
No, no, estoy de acuerdo, pero a lo que voy es que faltaba muchísimo.
Entre otras cosas, Gabi, que marca el 0-1, era un pilar fundamental de esta selección.
Capitán general.
Sí, sí, sí.
Entonces...
Pero que...
O sea, estoy de acuerdo, Nao, con tu premisa.
Pero que sea lícito plantear que el balón de oro y que decíamos que era el único futbolista
top mundial junto a Dani Carvajal, estando sano, que no recuperado, no sea indiscutible,
esto habla muy bien de Martín Zubimendi, habla de lo complicado que es recuperarse de una lesión
del ligamento cruzado y habla de que España no está anotando esa ausencia.
Yo tanto como...
O sea, entiendo lo que dice Adri, lo decíamos el otro día, ¿no?
O sea, si juega Martín Zubimendi por la razón que sea, España no va a perder el mundial
porque juega Martín Zubimendi.
No, no, no, ni mucho menos.
No, claro.
Pero es verdad que el mundial, que es una competición muy exigente, muy dura y a veces decía por un mínimo detalle,
pues igual no lo pierdes por Martín Zubimendi, que para mí es top 3 mundial en la posición,
pero igual sí lo ganas por tener a Rodri.
No sé si me explico.
Porque es un plus.
Pero a lo que voy es que es un castillo en el aire en el momento en que depende del estado en el que esté Rodri,
no ahora, sino en mayo.
Entonces, bueno, a mí, como dice Adri, yo estoy tranquilo cuando juega Martín Zubimendi.
Si está Rodri mejor y si no está Rodri 100% pues juega Martín Zubimendi.
Sí, sí, sí.
Estamos de acuerdo.
No, no, creo que estamos todos de acuerdo, simplemente que es el primer momento...
Creo que el debate, quiere decir...
Es un debate para mayo, estoy de acuerdo, pero te quiero decir que el hecho de que...
El debate cuando ves los primeros cuatro o cinco partidos de Zubimendi como titular con España,
dices sí, se puede plantear perfectamente, sí, Zubimendi o Rodri.
Incluso con Rodri el 100%, diría.
Está brillando muchísimo Zubimendi.
El tema es que yo creo que la gente se lo está planteando más ahora
porque creo que hay sensación de que el mundial está más cerca de lo que realmente está.
Ya, puede ser, puede ser.
Sí, porque al final quedan dos parones.
Quedan dos parones, claro.
Claro, no quedan tantos partidos.
Sí que es verdad.
De hecho, esto creo que lo comentamos un día.
No sé si aquí en Pizarritas o en La Pizarra,
pero si España no fuese sobrada de centrocampistas,
vamos a imaginar que no existe Fabián, no existe Pedri, no existe Barrios, ¿vale?
Sí.
Jugarían Rodri y Martín Zubimendi.
Como Muschietti y Sabia Alonso.
De eso lo planteamos varias veces.
Por eso.
Y el otro día se lo preguntaba en el libro de la fuente en rueda de prensa,
que si se lo planteaba en algún momento.
No es ninguna tontería, me parece complicado estando Pedri o estando Fabián,
sobre todo ellos dos, ¿no?
Si faltasen los dos, creo que ya sí que se podría abrir un poquito el abanico a esa cuestión.
Pero bueno, no deja de hablar de lo bien que está Zubimendi.
Ojalá, eso sí, llega al máximo nivel Rodri Hernández,
porque creo que te suma un plus.
Siete meses y pico, solo que hay todavía casi ocho.
Sí, sí, solo que creo que...
Le da tiempo a Rodri a volver y ganar la Champions.
Ah, creo que sí.
Claro, claro.
Igual, estábamos planteando este debate en octubre.
Sí.
Que llega Rodri como centrocampista titular del campeón de la Champions,
que no sea una locura.
Sí, sí, no, no, ni mucho menos.
Sí, yo lo que digo es que creo que es el primer momento
en el que hay conciencia este parón
de que igual Rodri no llega bien.
O sea, es el primer momento.
Bueno, pero muy precipitado, quiero decir.
Sí, pero...
Está poniendo una lesión de cruzado y le queda toda la temporada delante.
¿Sabes también por qué creo que se abre el debate?
Porque Zubimendi lo está haciendo en el Arsenal.
Claro.
Bueno, pero...
Eso sí, yo creo que sobre todo.
La Real Sociedad muy bien.
Lo veíamos nosotros y lo veíamos los oficiales de la Real Sociedad.
Pero ahora ya creo que lo está viendo todo el mundo.
Tengo creo que un editorial que digo que Zubimendi
ya es uno de los mejores mediocentros del mundo,
solo en Edita Fichar por el Arsenal para que la gente lo vea.
No para que lo sea.
No para que lo sea, sino para que la gente lo vea.
Que esto es el fútbol, nos guste más o menos.
Y ahora tiene partidos de Champions contra los españoles,
el Atlético de Madrid muy próximo.
Bueno, pues que se baje...
Estuvo en San Mamés, que es un Atleti Club, no hace nada.
Que se baje dos tonitos, Martín Zubimendi,
contra los equipos españoles.
Segunda cuestión de Sopado.
¿Creéis que una temporada...
Me va a decir lo mismo, Nahuel, queda mucho.
Queda mucho.
Pero vamos a imaginar un territorio...
Es que queda mucho.
¿Creéis que una temporada así, lesiones,
y a muy buen nivel de Alejandro Valdé
puede sentar a Cucurella en el Mundial?
¿Y carreras?
Bueno, pero esto...
O sea, quiero decir que para esto no queda mucho
en el sentido de...
Estamos hablando de un mundo hipotético
en el que están todos al 100%.
No es la de...
Ella va siendo hora de plantear el debate.
Vale, vale, vale.
Por lo menos es el caso hipotético, están todos al 100%.
Yo a Cucurella no lo siento por ningún lateral en el mundo.
Quizá por Nuno Méndez, pero ya está.
Por Nuno, igual sí.
Sí, por Nuno sí.
Pero con pena.
Encima, en esta selección, ¿no?
Quiero decir, sobre todo en el contexto de esta selección,
para otros contextos podemos sentarnos y hablar.
Pero ni por Valdé, ni el mejor carrera
para mí, si entran a Cucurella.
Este me gusta porque en el Barça...
En el Barça, igual teniendo Cundé en el otro lado,
sí que pondría a Valdé.
No, no, claro.
Pero es que estamos hablando de la selección.
Sí, sí, no, no.
Pero como tú has dicho, que en otros contextos,
en otros equipos...
¿Estás seguro?
No lo sé, no lo sé.
Yo no tengo tan claro.
No sé, por ejemplo...
Incluso a carreras en el Barça.
A mí es que Nuno Méndez...
A carreras en el Barça.
A mí me parece que Nuno Méndez es el lateral perfecto
para cualquier contexto.
No, no, no.
Cucurella, estamos diciendo.
Ah, vale.
Cucurella, Mar Cucurella,
candelano del Barça, estuvo en el Getafe,
también llamado...
En el Eibar.
En el Eibar también.
Un fichaje...
No, en el Eibar.
Estaba que estábamos hablando del tema Nuno.
En el Eibar estaba Cucurella.
Fue en el Getafe, el de Cucurella.
Yo creo que Cucurella sentaría carreras en el Madrid.
A Valdé en el Barça no lo sé, por el hecho de Cundé.
No por otra cosa.
En todo caso, Adriález, estáis de acuerdo con Nahuel
y suscribo que...
No de cable.
No depende ni de carreras ni de Valdé.
Depende de si Cucurella está sano.
Sí, tal cual.
Intocable, intocable.
Además, hace poco analizábamos aquí en el canal
el rol que tiene dentro de la selección,
como lateral defensivo, para ayudar a su extremo.
Y creo que para ese rol, Cucurella es el mejor.
Y creo que luego, además, Grimaldo ha asumido muy bien
el hecho de ser suplente y el hecho de cómo
entra bien a los partidos que tiene que entrar.
Es decir, cuando, por ejemplo, se le requiere un momento de España,
tiene que buscar mucho centro lateral,
tiene que abusar de eso, Grimaldo te lo va a dar
y te lo va a dar con precisión.
Y te digo más, Álex, tiene mucho mérito,
porque Grimaldo llegaba muy bien a la Eurocopa
y para todos iba a ser el titular.
Sí, sí, sí.
Y a Cucurella le adelanta y...
Yo aquí metería tres variables, ¿vale?
O sea, Cucurella indiscutible, titularísimo, bla, bla, bla.
Tres variables.
Una, si Cucurella está bien y es el titular,
me gusta mucho como suplente de Grimaldo.
Por estilo...
Tiene mérito lo de Grimaldo, ahora que es lo del mérito de Cucurella.
Tiene mérito lo de Grimaldo, que parece que llegaba porque era la moda,
porque es un español, no hay equipo de moda del fútbol europeo,
¿cómo no lo vas a llevar?
Pero creo que ha sabido primero en el Bayern Leverkusen
demostrar que no era cosa de una temporada.
Y luego encontró su lugar también en la selección,
me parecía complicado por ser un perfil tan diferente precisamente al de Cucurella.
Totalmente, pues decía que hay como varias derivadas.
Una es esa de, para mí Grimaldo, contexto de partido,
sale Grimaldo por Cucurella porque tengo que atacar,
prefiero a Grimaldo.
Si no estuviese en banda Nico Williams y si hubiera Alejandro Baena,
que podría ser una opción, o un Dani Olmo,
mi opción sería Alejandro Valde como suplente,
ojo, como suplente, no como titular, titular siempre Cucurella,
y si Cucurella se lesionase,
para alterar lo mínimo posible, mi opción sería Carreras.
O sea, fijaros lo complejo que puede llegar a ser
todo donde tú puedes decir, vale, el que más me gusta es este,
luego este, luego este, luego este, ya, ya, pero ¿para qué?
Sobre todo porque son jugadores de mucho nivel,
es que estamos eligiendo en lateral titular del Chelsea,
lateral titular del Baile Berkusen, lateral titular del Madrid,
lateral titular del Barça, coño.
Sobre todo porque Valde creo que donde más puede crecer
es precisamente en ese apartado defensivo,
y no ha terminado de dar ese paso,
es verdad que obviamente ha tenido un periodo complicado
con el tema de las lesiones, etcétera,
pero vamos, es donde yo creo que se podría,
donde está la diferencia entre que Valde vaya con la selección o que no.
Oye, me acabo de dar cuenta que creo que he cogido,
o no es de él, o he cogido una segunda pregunta de Tecchio Ryoku No Mau,
es posible que me haya equivocado yo, ¿vale?
Pero plantea una cuestión interesante, sea él o sea otro.
Lo bueno, lo bueno es que va a estar corregido en el rótulo de aquí abajo.
Muy bien, porque tenemos a nuestro Alexander,
que es capaz incluso de saber cuándo equivocarse.
44 nombres en el draft, ¿con cuál se equivocó?
Con Verbal.
Verbal.
No, como lo escribió Verbal.
Que me gusta mucho la pregunta porque dice,
después de España, ¿vale?
Y con esto vamos acabando el Q&A de selecciones, podríamos decir.
Después de España, el mejor centro del campo lo tiene Holanda,
de John Grabenberg, Rangers.
Para mí sí, Rangers, sí.
Portugal, ¿con quién sería tu centro del campo?
Bruno, Vitinha, Joao.
Bueno, es que Joao ya veremos si juega en la de la derecha.
Rubén Neves, Vitinha, Bruno.
Es que tiene de todo.
A mí de Pariña me parece un poco horroroso,
pero creo que es un jugador.
No me gusta el perfil de jugador que es,
y creo que teniendo tanto crack no debería jugar,
pero bueno, ahí está, no sé.
¿Y el de Argentina?
De Paul McAllister, Enzo.
¿De Paul McAllister, Enzo?
Me gusta.
El de polco en Argentina es mucho mejor de lo que todos tenemos.
Mucho mejor futbolista.
A mí de Europa me parece mejor el de Países Bajos que el de Portugal.
Claro, creo que también el contexto es más favorable
en Países Bajos que en Portugal.
Para que brillen, quiero decir.
Porque Vitinha ¿en qué escenario le hemos visto brillar?
En un país Saint-Germain súper dominante,
un país Saint-Germain que tiene mucho balón, etc.
En Portugal no le da eso.
Si lo piensas, el Grabenberg de John Rangers
es bastante complementario.
Aquí vemos a un ranger más llegador.
Ya lo vimos, por ejemplo, en la pasada Eurocopa.
Pero...
Qué gracia me hace como pronunciar rangers.
Como si fuera un Power Ranger.
Glasgow.
Sí, sí, sí, lo pronuncio mal.
Pero me parece muy complementario.
Está bien tirado.
Yo soy viudo del mejor centro del campo de la Uruguay de Bielsa.
El Vendancur Valverde de Nico de la Cruz
es un centro del campo para mirar los ojitos a cualquiera.
Pero Nico tuvo problemas de lesiones.
¿Puedes volver a repetir qué centro del campo
mira los ojitos a cualquiera?
No, no.
El Vendancur Valverde de Nico de la Cruz mira los ojos a cualquiera.
Te lo defiendo contra quien quieras.
Y de Arrasca.
De Arrasca no puedes sustituir a la Cruz.
Es que está jugando bastante más arriba.
Está jugando bastante más de nueve ahora en Flamengo.
Y nunca ha terminado de caer de pie.
Aunque teníamos partidos con la selección.
Ha entrado a jugarte por Nico de la Cruz,
que creo que le da un poco más de consistencia,
pero le quita un poco de brillantez.
En fin, que soy viudo de ese centro del campo hace dos años.
Quería que ibas a ser viudo del Ruso Pérez,
Arevalo Ríos,
Gargano.
Gargano, Gargano.
El centro del campo era la hostia.
Bueno, pero Gargano no jugaba tanto con ellos.
Juega con el Tata.
El Tata González.
El Tata, el Tata.
Era un buen jugador, pero parecía mejor cuando estaba Egidio,
estaba Ruso Pérez y decías Tata.
Le decías coño, es Recova.
No, pero claro, al lado de mis primos...
El Tata.
El Tata que era...
Tata, Tata, Tata, Tata, Tata, Tata.
Tata, Tata, Tata, Tata, Tata.
No hay que reírle las gracias.
Esto lo estoy aprendiendo con Hugo.
Porque a veces valía y no hay que reírle las gracias porque...
Me refiero a esto, es que no me ha salido bien el ritmo.
¿Puedo enseñar?
A ver, si pones una música, nos cancelan el vídeo.
Entonces, encima de haberte escuchado, encima nos cobramos.
No, no.
No, que no cobre él.
A ver...
Es que no lo voy a encontrar.
No le pagues a Dejano tu porcentaje de los tringues.
Me dejas que lo vaya buscando y seguís y ahora os lo pongo.
Te deje o no, lo vas a hacer, así que...
Tampoco hace falta, Álex.
Sí que es muy gracioso.
Hay barcos que pasan y está bien que pasen.
Pues ya está, ya igual, que pase.
Cuarta cuestión.
¿Sabéis de quién?
Fer Pulpillo.
¡Hombre, Fer Pulpillo!
Fer Pulpillo es una ametralladora, deja 5 o 6 cuestiones.
Y ahí el reto es quedarte solo con una, le hacen muy buenas preguntas.
Y hace una, Álex, que...
Venimos hablando más off the record que otra cosa, porque no hemos tocado exactamente el tema.
Pero pregunta Fer, ¿es Birch, por ahora, la gran decepción del fútbol europeo?
Yo creo que la respuesta es sí.
La cuestión es, ¿qué está pasando?
Yo creo que se va a mover en la gran decepción del fútbol europeo, básicamente, primero, por obviamente lo que se pagó por él.
O sea, es que eso va a ser... va a estar...
Si hubiera empezado la temporada con 5 goles, 5 asistencias, no estaríamos diciendo nada a esto, por ejemplo.
Pero tan pesimista eres, ¿no crees que va a remontar el vuelo?
O sea, yo creo que puede remontarlo, por supuesto.
Pero es que me da la sensación de que Slot y él están en dos sintonías diferentes, ¿sabes?
Entonces es lo que quieres decir.
Sí, pues está Steven Gerrard ahí esperando, ¿no? A ver si se da.
No, pero mi sensación es que Birch quiere jugar en el rol por fuera que tiene influencia por dentro
y le está metiendo en una posición muy fija, que es la de la media punta del Liverpool,
en la que él, yo creo que no termina de estar cómodo, en la que cuando le hemos visto su mejor partido con el Liverpool,
yo te diría que es la segunda parte ante el Arsenal, que es en la que se suelta más, baja a recibir, se lateraliza un poco...
En definitiva entra más en contacto con el balón.
Y yo sinceramente pensaba que iba a ser ese el rol, porque además si una fortaleza tuvo Liverpool el año pasado,
es que el centro del campo de tres le funcionó muy bien.
Con Graben Birch Macalister tiene una versión impresionante, con Soboslai que ahora lo está ubicando en lateral
y que eso también obviamente, pues al equipo a veces se lo hace notar.
Y en definitiva te diría que sí.
Es curioso lo que dices, porque hablas de que la posición le está complicando un poco...
Jesús, no...
Le está complicando...
Hattrick, Hattrick, se lleva el balón a casa...
Habla... Decías que va de dentro hacia afuera y que es un poco incómodo,
en Alemania está jugando demasiado por fuera, o sea, y demasiado lejos de dónde está la pelota.
En Alemania, el otro día estuve viendo el partido contra Irlanda del Norte, que creo que ya lo he comentado alguna vez,
que juega Kimmich en el lado derecho.
Entonces, aunque Kimmich no sea centrocampista, el balón va a ir a Kimmich, porque es un jugador que organiza,
aunque sea desde el lateral.
Entonces claro, tienes a Birch como extremo del lado débil.
Te dices, coño, es que es rarísimo. Y estuvo muy mal, el partido fue muy malo.
Es muy raro, es evidente.
Y seguramente ni Slot en el Liverpool ni Nagelsmann en Alemania estén entendiendo
que deben dar a Birch para que luzca, pero si no funciona con el club y tampoco con la selección,
es porque él no está bien. Es decir, es un futbolista que ya lo demostraba en el Leverkusen,
se movía muy bien en distintas zonas y en el espacio reducido era un jugador que era una baldosa...
Pero no puede tener Birch un poco el tema, por compararle,
porque siempre hemos hablado de Birch, Musiala y Bellingham.
Un poco lo que le puede pasar a Bellingham, de no saber exactamente...
De su hueco, ¿no? De encontrar su hueco.
De su hueco y de qué habilidades explotar.
Quiero decir, porque creo que son jugadores, y esto también pasaría con Musiala,
pero son jugadores que pueden hacer muchas cosas y ser muchas cosas,
pero ¿cuál eliges y cuál necesitas como equipo?
Porque a veces igual no va de la mano, no sé si me explico.
Igual el Real Madrid necesita al Bellingham más llegador, pero Bellingham es mejor en otras cosas.
Igual el Liverpool necesita a Birch entre líneas, pero Birch entre líneas puede ser un buen jugador,
pero no es el mismo futbolista con esa capacidad para moverse.
Creo que era el único jugador del sistema de Alonso que había mucho intercambio posicional y mucho movimiento.
Pero el que tenía libertad para decidir era Birch.
Era el que se podía saltar las cosas. Y yo no le estoy viendo eso en el Liverpool.
Claro, a mí esto por ejemplo...
Tú sabes, Miguel, que yo tuve que hacer una vez un ejercicio de cómo adaptar Florian Birch al Arsenal.
Lo hablamos.
Ahí había que adaptar al lateral que tenías en ese lado a quien tenías en el otro sector
y sobre todo cómo eran los interiores para que no se pisaran la misma zona además del 9.
Obviamente si tú te ciñes en lo más estadístico dices, coño,
si Florian Birch es tener como una radiografía de Martín Odegaard, pero en lugar de en el sector derecho, digamos, en el izquierdo.
Pero es que esto no funciona así. Desgraciadamente el futbol no es como en el FIFA o en el fútbol de maestro que lo pones y chau.
Aquí tienes que encajar demasiadas situaciones además también de cosas personales.
Yo, una de las cosas que sí que he alucinado un poco es que en The Athletic preguntaron a gente, a representantes,
oye, ¿cuál creéis que va a ser la decepción o el fichaje de decepción de esta temporada?
Y le ponía a todo el mundo votación. Creo que la votación era todos los votos a Sesco por el Manchester United.
Y creo que un representante había votado a Birch y otro a Isaac.
O sea que eran como 20 representantes ya.
El tema del Manchester United es tiro a tablero también.
El tema con Birch era joven.
Es claramente, quitando a Salah, que es una leyenda del club, es el mejor jugador del equipo.
Entonces yo creo que viene a Liverpool a hacer por adaptarse a él, igual que Alemania.
Y le está pasando con Salah. Yo creo que también le está pasando con Salah.
Aunque como Salah no está tan bien, creo que eso está haciendo que Birch no esté tan bien.
Porque Birch está generando. Creo que lleva generadas como tres o cuatro ocasiones claras.
Pero genera está jugando mal. Birch es tan bueno, por eso cuesta tanto.
Que incluso estando mal es un jugador que te va a producir.
Pero de nuevo, temporadas son larguísimas.
A estas alturas de la pasada temporada, Mbappé parecía a Izan Mbappé.
Ya le gustaría.
Qué golazo metió el otro día al PSG.
Lo celebró Killing, lo celebró Kiki.
Ah sí?
Claro, claro.
Está en la grada.
Entonces, calma. Esto de que Gagpo vaya a sentar a Florian Birch...
No, eso no.
No, eso no. Pero que digo que lo más lógico sería ver a Birch en la posición de Gagpo.
Sí, sí.
Es que a mí Gagpo, siendo un jugador que me gusta, estamos hablando de un escalón sencilla y inferior al resto.
De hecho, yo no hubiese...
Supongo que porque no tenías la misma oferta, la misma gestión y demás, por supuesto.
Pero si tú puedes elegir, yo me quedo con Luis Díaz y no con Gagpo.
No me lo has afacido.
No, pero es un debate que he leído en Twitter muchas veces.
No, es que Slot, Slot yo creo que no tengo esa duda. Slot dijo, mira, llevamos a Luis Díaz.
Es verdad que...
Yo creo que a Slot no le terminaba de molar Luis Díaz demasiado.
Luis tiene pinta de haber sido un poco intenso a nivel del día a día.
O flamenco.
Por lo que...
No será Slot un poquito de la cuerda de Bangal.
No sé quién declaró el otro día aquello de que no soportaba a los sudamericanos.
Bangal, claro. Se movían los sudamericanos por lo que sea.
Riquelme, Rivaldo...
No recuerdo quién es la declaración, lo encontraré.
Riquelme dice bastante gracia y tiene un respaldo.
Sí, sí, sí, sí, no, no.
María Falcao...
No, no, la forma de entender el fútbol del jugador sudamericano, mucho más relacionista,
por ejemplo ahora lo estamos viendo con Argentina, pero en general,
eso que se conocía como la nuestra en Argentina y sigue ahí,
no, no, no, con el fútbol de Luis Bangal no funciona.
No cuadra.
Oye, Riquelme, puedes asistir dos goles, marcar uno y tal,
pero si te he dicho que estés en la banda, estate en la banda.
Pero lo mejor, yo me leí la biografía de Bangal que además no se publicó en castellano,
entonces me la tuve que leer en inglés y ya sabéis que mi inglés, pues Alan Piz.
Tuve que hacer un ejercicio mastodóntico.
El caso cuenta Bangal en esa autobiografía, creo que no es autobiografía, pero bueno,
me entendéis, que él aprende que no puede encasillar los talentos,
en el AZ, después de todo de que había fracasado, en el AZ con el Handawe y ahora se me ha olvidado
quién era el otro delantero, pero en el AZ que creo que sale campeón,
dice por fin he entendido que hay que hacer excepciones y dices cabrón,
este Arribaldo, Riquelme, y lo entiendo.
Muy de Luis Bangal, por cierto, como persona y como profesional.
Y como libreta.
Y como libreta, pero es verdad que un poquito tal.
Con Ale, pasemos ya a la Liga, ¿vale?
¿Creéis que Corberán sobrevivirá a la trituradora de entradores de Méridon?
Parece que se le ha caído el equipo en el riguroso octubre,
¿podrá realzarlo encima Calendario Chungo?
Este es un tema que habíamos dejado abierto,
Valencia no salvó a Pau Novich en ese partido, pero...
Vais a flipar quién era el otro delantero de la AZ.
Dembele, el Dembele del Tottenham.
Sí, el Dembele del Tottenham, que luego es centrocampista.
Es Musa Dembele, ¿no?
Musa con Aésea, ¿no?
¿Qué creéis que va a pasar con el Valencia?
Porque en este calendario que hace que los primeros meses sean como escalones
o como etapas, la primera etapa, bueno, la segunda dices, eh,
y ya la tercera se puede torcer, yo no sé si irremediablemente, pero ya...
Sí, sí.
Yo creo que le da la vuelta, eh.
A la Vestilla Real, Madrid-Betis, eh.
Sí, Belka, Calendario es complicado, pero yo creo que lo saca.
El otro día nos contaba en la pizarra Luis Cortés la información que publicaba
Diego Pico en marca, que Corberán convocó a los capitanes en su despacho
45 minutos para hablar con ellos, para calmar un poco la situación,
para reconducir un poco la dinámica, y creo que lo saca.
Creo que lo saca. Me parece buen entrenador y que puede darle la vuelta.
Pues yo, como os he comentado, mi teoría más allá del análisis,
creo que es acertado, que el equipo no está bien, que no encuentra sensaciones,
que ha desconectado mucho con la grada, yo creo que eso lo vemos todos.
Es que Corberán es su propio jefe.
Es que Corberán manda fichar a Ron Gurley, que es el que le ficha en su día
para el West Brom.
Creo que debería darse una situación irreconducible dentro del mal calendario
que tiene el Valencia al final.
Sales a Mendizorroza, que tampoco es la última mazmorra,
y luego de los siguientes cuatro partidos hay tres en casa,
que son Villarreal, Betis y Levante.
No me parece el peor de los calendarios tampoco.
Creo que con muy poquito más este Valencia puede cambiar.
Y ya digo, sobre todo, creo que Corberán debería estar en descenso
faltando cinco jornadas para acabar la liga, para ser destituido.
Creo que ya es el entrenador al que han puesto para...
Oye, que me gestionen esto entre Ron Gurley y Corberán
y que hagan lo que puedan.
Que no molesten mucho.
Que no molesten mucho y ya está.
La gente se les una con Europa y no se ha colmado esa expectativa.
Igual este parón, esta mala racha, sirve un poco para recalcular objetivos.
Insisto, yo no veo al Valencia sufriendo ni a Corberán cerca de la picota.
No, o sea, yo de la picota no, pero creo que este escalón,
llamémoslo así, es muy complejo.
Pero muy complejo.
Y a nivel de juego creo que tiene que cambiar mucho las cosas.
A la vez es fuera o en casa?
A la vez es fuera.
Es que fuera son el Bernabéu y Mendizorroza.
En casa es Villarreal y Betis.
Cuidado, eh.
Claro, es que me parecen cuatro partidos que perfectamente...
O sea, yo puedo comprar lo que dice Nahuel de la...
de esa teoría.
Me parece que tiene mucho sentido y es un puntito cínica,
pero es que es así como hay que actuar con mérito ni complejo.
Con mérito ni compañía.
Pero claro, imagínate, vamos a ponernos en un mal escenario.
Sé que es fútbol ficción, pero te ponés en un mal escenario
que puede llegar a ser probable.
De estos 12 puntos posibles, vamos a decir que sacas dos, ¿vale?
Que tampoco es un disparate, joder, no es un disparate.
Claro, de repente te ves en una situación en la tabla,
decepcionante respecto a esas expectativas quizás,
algo exagerada, ya lo comentamos en su día en verano,
que se habían hecho con los fichajes,
notas a algún jugador incómodo, otro rebrincado,
qué pasa con Raba, qué pasa con el otro,
Gallac que ya ha tenido algún momento de llegar a no parecer
intocable para lo que es incluso la afición y dices,
ostia, que se me comienza a complicar.
Entonces yo no creo que en esa situación ni siquiera en esa
situación fueras a ser destituido,
pero sí que comienzas a acercarte a una situación sin retorno
y la situación sin retorno, más tarde o más temprano,
se solucionan de la misma manera.
Sí, porque no tienen retorno, básicamente,
como su propio nombre indica, ¿no, Miguel?
Pero sí que a mí no me parece que sea un...
o sea, yo creo que al Valencia están muy lejos ahora mismo,
yo creo que quizá a la vez le puedes meter un poquito más y demás.
Me han dicho roza cuidado, ¿eh?
Sí, me han dicho roza cuidado, pero bueno,
me parecería un partido que el Valencia podría sacar adelante,
podría sacar un empate, pongámoslo así,
pero es que los otros tres me parecen súper complejos.
Pero al Valencia se le complican todos,
pero los otros tres, por ejemplo, el del Betis en casa lo gana,
el del Bernabéu la temporada pasada lo gana,
el Villarreal empata en casa también la pasada temporada,
quiero decir.
Pero creo que el Bernabéu el año pasado
era en unas condiciones muy diferentes.
No, no, pero lo de Villarreal y Betis fue como baraja.
El empate a uno, que fue el partido de antes
de la famosa noche de Rafa Amir,
y el del Betis, que fue el primer partido de la semana.
El vuelca vuelta.
El que también tiene ese asterisco.
Bueno, quiero decir, o sea, el Valencia,
yo creo que al Valencia ahora mismo,
también por lo que ha sido el atrédito del recorrido del Valencia fuera de casa,
es que cualquier salida dice, buf, cuidado.
Pero, peri, a mendizo, Rosa,
es que no me parece uno de los diez campos más complicados de primera edición.
También creo que las palabras de Corberán,
tras perder ante el Oviedo,
son las que nos ponen un poco a todos en la pista
de que algo está pasando dentro.
Pero uno ve a jugar el Valencia,
la verdad es que viene de un empate y dos derrotas,
no es ni que poca esté muerto.
De hecho, no está ni muerto,
no está ni muerto,
ni te diría que tampoco está herido.
Lo verdad es que no está, como el año pasado,
que esto ya dijimos que era muy difícil de sostener,
porque el Valencia hizo puntuación casi Champions,
y ni de coña tiene plantilla casi Champions.
Porque la intensidad de Corberán la puedes comprar cuando eres colista
y es que te vas a asegurar.
Y generas una dinámica y te sonríen los resultados porque,
yo lo dije, pero no dije al comienzo de esta temporada,
lo dije al final de la pasada, creo que el Valencia estaba sobrepuntuando,
estaba llevándose muchos partidos.
Pues el año pasado el de Oviedo se lo lleva.
¿Por qué? Porque...
Sí, mismamente,
te iba a decir porque marca el penalti de Dany Yuma a 2-0 y a tomar por saco.
Y sin embargo se te complica,
esas cosas que llamamos dinámicas.
Es verdad que estás decimo quinto,
pero volvemos a lo que dijimos en verano.
Si es que el Valencia lo que tiene que aspirar es a salvarse
mitad de abril, final de abril,
y a ver si puedo tener un poquito de espacio para ilusionarme.
Pero si empiezas margándote la expectativa de la ilusión,
se te va a ir la cabeza.
Porque es que no pueden hacerlo prácticamente ningún equipo,
y no se puede hacer nada.
Y es que el Valencia está en un momento
en que se va a hacer la decisión del Real Oviedo
que tiene que pelear por Europa.
Vamos a regalar la camiseta Gambéa.
¡Oh!
Hemos tenido muchas dudas.
Vamos a decir los dos candidatos finales.
Vale. Vale.
Equipete Fútbol Club. ¡Oy! Bien.
Y Ursera Gout. ¡Oh! Vale.
Vídeos espectaculares, trabajo en redes espectaculares.
Y ha sido difícil quedarse con uno.
Muy difícil.
Pero por ese vídeo que han hecho propio,
y voy a volver a repetirlo, de Alfred Hitchcock...
¡Oh! ¡Diii!
...Ursera Gout se lleva la equipación de Gambéa personalizada
para la próxima temporada.
Espectacular.
Me sabe mal por Equipete Fútbol Club, que lo ha hecho maravilloso.
Ha hecho un vídeo, además, fantástico, metiéndose...
Bueno, no me has metido en ese con nosotros,
pero jugando un poquito en los roles que al final no dejamos de tener cada uno.
Y nada, os animamos a pagarlo vosotros.
Si vosotros lo pagáis, Gambéa os lo hace.
Podemos llegar...
Premio de consolación.
¿Algún descuentillo?
Se lo voy a pasar a la gente Gambéa.
Se lo voy a pasar a la gente Gambéa un 20%.
¡Venga!
No he hablado nada con Gambéa.
Tampoco me voy a apilar los dedos.
Un 10.
Prometemos moverlo con Gambéa.
Vamos a moverlo con Gambéa.
Es increíble, Nahuel Miranda.
No regala nada, pero es que tira de pragmatismo.
No, no, no.
¿Sabes lo que regalo yo?
Tu camiseta de Gambéa del Panathinauticos.
Que sale de mi bolsillo.
¡Calladito!
¡La tengo!
Te iba a elogiar porque estábamos viendo a Nahuel Miranda
en la temporada más maduro, más hecho, más derecho también.
Y tú te lo has tomado mal.
Un hombre.
Un hombre sí.
No regala nada.
Fíjate tú por dónde.
Que sí que te he regalado y encima de Gambéa.
Era metafórico.
¿Estás bien, Nahuel?
Sí, sí.
¿Estás en tu mejor momento?
Siempre.
No, siempre no.
El mejor momento es el ahora, ¿no?
Sí, sí.
No hay otro.
Pero es estar muerto.
Hablando de grandes momentos.
Babu Bilu.
Es mejor eso que morirse.
Babu Bibu.
Vale, pregunta.
¿Visto el nivel del Englet?
No concreta.
Dice ¿visto el nivel del Englet?
Vale.
Si lo has visto, sabes cuál es.
¿No sería más adecuado jugar con Hasco
de central-zurdo y colocar
Agadam barra Ruggeri
en el lateral?
Yo no compraba esto a comienzo de temporada.
Lo compro ahora.
Yo creo que Ruggeri puede dar más de
lo que da el Englet
como central.
Ruggeri puede dar más como lateral-izquierdo
que lo que da el Englet como central.
Entonces, yo creo que hay
una oportunidad de Ruggeri
la debemos ver pronto.
Nos dicen en comentarios y creo que tienen
parte la razón de que somos muy haters con Ruggeri
porque una cosa es no ver
a ese lateral de 20 millones
que te va a solucionar el problema del lateral-izquierdo
que de momento no lo hemos visto ni de cerca.
De los millones que lo que ha pagado la Lety.
Claro, claro.
A mí me hace mucha gracia porque
hay gente que habla
de Ruggeri como si Ruggeri hubiera llegado gratis.
Ahí estoy de acuerdo.
Si Ruggeri sube del filial
de la cantera.
No hay duda.
Vale, pues a ver qué puedo aportar.
Como cuesta 20 millones.
Pero 20 millones en el mercado actual,
¿qué es? Sí, pero ¿cuántas veces la Lety
ha gastado 20 millones en un lateral?
Pues en Nahuel Molina y en Ruggeri.
Y a ver cuándo va a volver a gastarlo.
Porque estos clásicos me los conozco.
Ahora vamos a ver qué tal con Alemán.
Pero vamos a verlo porque no es fácil.
O Jonico González
que ha jugado ya con Argentina
y con el Atlántico.
Era una derivada que los iba a preguntar luego.
Pero a lo que voy es que una cosa es que el fichaje
no nos pueda convencer y que nos parezca sobrepagado
por lo que estamos viendo y por lo que le conocimos
o lo vimos en el Atalanta.
Y otra cosa es que sí que creo
que con lo que hay ahora,
la mejor defensa, la mejor combinación posible
con lo que hay ahora, incluye a Ruggeri
en el lateral izquierdo. Aunque solo sea
porque a mí me gusta más que ganar
y porque creo que lo del englete
es insostenible.
Y si Ruggeri no mejora el nivel,
para mí ya debe jugar.
Pero es que para mí empeora mucho
Hansko jugando de central
respecto a jugando de lateral, que le veo muy cómodo
y de central creo que le cuesta.
A mí me gusta de central, Hansko.
Es que creo que es
fuerza que sufre mucho con el juego directo
y creo que solo el Atlético de Madrid lo notó
en las primeras jornadas. A mí me parece natural
meter a la izquierda porque
ni Galán ni Ruggeri son
futbolistas que te hagan perder la cabeza
y porque dices
oye, es que entre
Galán o Ruggeri y el englete
pues si me da igual.
Entonces voy a poner a Hansko
en el central.
Hansko está jugando como central, prácticamente.
Si está cerrando con tres, será Letty muchas veces.
No, si cierras con tres a tope. Pero en línea de cuatro
atrás, que lo hemos visto mucho a principio de temporada,
no me gusta. Pero tú dices nada.
Ruggeri no es para perder
la cabeza, totalmente de acuerdo. Pero es que
el englete te la hace perder, porque te lleva
locura. O sea, el englete es como hacer un draft.
Porque es que no sabes de qué
manera te va a fallar. Es la
realidad. Es que jugadores así son muy
difíciles de asumir.
Había un dato que sacaron los amigos de Atlético Stats.
Vamos a buscarlo y lo ponemos en pantalla. Lo estaréis
viendo ahora vosotros, pizarritas.
De los penaltis y rojas
en los partidos.
Godín, Miranda,
lejísimos. Jiménez creo que era el otro.
Y el englete ya está ahí
en el top con unos pocos partidos.
Salía un penalti o expulsión
cada muy pocos partidos.
Y esas son las acciones
más graves.
Pero tiene acciones
que no cuentan en ese
gráfico.
A mí me dan ganas
de arrancarme los ojos en el Atlético
de Madrid, ver a un jugador que no sabe
qué hacer con la pelota. Y a mí Galán y Ruggeri
me dejan esa sensación.
Con pelota es mejor, Ruggeri, de lo que dices.
Es feo de ver.
A mí me parece horrible.
Pero parece horrible.
Entonces, bueno…
Desde que Nawel dijo eso de Starfell,
cuidado. O sea que igual está
invocando el espíritu Nawel
para que Ruggeri sea ahora
candidato a la 11 de la liga.
Starfell cuidado, que ha pasado más tiempo lesionado
que jugando. Es el Starfell cuidado.
No, no.
No, no, no. Macho, que me tuve
que ir al coliseum.
Que me tuve que ir al coliseum con una camiseta de Starfell.
Y bueno, la tenemos que dejar.
Nawel, que me tuve que ir con una camiseta de Starfell
al coliseum.
Y a pedir perdón.
Me tuve que beber
varias pintas con la gente.
Para que me digan lo tuyo.
Encima la pagó mi déjela.
Bueno, bueno. Encima no trincó.
Tampoco.
No recuerdo haber pagado nada ese día, la verdad.
Robin Hood, el periodismo español,
no pago en esta tampoco.
Yo tampoco muevo a Janco
de la izquierda. A mí también me está gustando
igual que a Nawel.
Confío en él ahí.
Y quiero creer en la resurrección de Josema.
Tendrá que volver algún día.
Hombre, ya ha vuelto de hecho.
Digo yo. Digo yo.
Que él le baja la ficha.
Pero hombre, tendrá que volver.
Yo os iba a plantear, porque como lo de Jiménez,
es que ya me cuesta, os iba a plantear una alternativa
con una cosa que ya habéis comentado,
lo de Nico, ¿vale? Que creo que
os puedo convencer a todos.
1 a 1, ¿vale?
Alex, Nico,
voy a ir 1 a 1.
Creo que sé lo que vas a decir.
Lo digo.
La línea de tres, ¿vale?
Con Marcos Llorente de central derecho,
Lenormán y Hansko
con Nico de carrilero.
No, no, no.
Nico, casi, casi porque me conoces, cabrón.
Ya hablamos demasiado. Nico,
carrilero izquierdo, Hansko
central izquierdo, desde luego.
Rubi Lenormán, central en el medio.
Mar Pubil,
Marcos Llorente.
El otro día en el entrenamiento
probó a Carlos Martín.
Ya, bueno, pero...
Bueno.
Al cónjol hace el otro día, por cierto.
Yo le daría más coba
a Pubil.
Yo también.
Pero creéis que pondría
antes a Pubil de central que a Marcos Llorente?
Que bueno, tampoco...
Yo lo digo porque sé que aquí me estoy cargando
a Juliano, pero yo...
Me gusta mucho el ajustar roles, ¿vale?
Creo que Pubil puede ser ese central
y yo no he confiado mucho, pero lo que he visto...
Tiene altura de central, de hecho.
Llorente, yo vengo pidiendo
acercarlo más...
acercarlo más al área, libertad, y eso lo puedo hacer.
Y Juliano, yo siempre he insistido
que para mí, aunque ha sido titular
con razón, en un Atlético de Madrid
algo más pleno y con más
fichajes, su rol ideal es
ser jugador número 12 y número 13.
Eso significa jugar muchísimo, pero
el 11 ideal no es este.
Entonces, ahí a la hora de reajustar roles
me gustaría
ver eso. Luego igual sale horrible,
sabes, pero...
Ya que os acabo el nombre de Jiménez
dando un saltito, adelantando
la siguiente línea, empiezan a estar
muy mosquedados los Atléticos
y creo que con razón, con Johnny.
Mostraros Johnny es increíble.
El tobillo de Johnny Cardoso, ¿eh?
¡Primonitorio aquello de...
Johnny, la gente está muy loca!
Cuidadito, cuidado ese tobillo.
Es que lo del tobillo de Johnny es increíble.
Me gusta la ref de Nao.
Lo celebro, la celebro, porque es de mi época.
Cesqueto,
sin llevarnos por...
No, perdón, sin llevarnos por el hype,
que eso es complicado con nosotros,
no vamos a engañar a la gente.
Ya nos conocéis.
¿Qué nivel pensáis que puede alcanzar
Eta y John?
Lo veis como el recambio de Robert Lewandowski.
Ha habido una barbaridad.
No iba a coger esta cuestión,
porque ya hablaremos del tema del reemplazo
del nuevo Lewandowski, pero hombre, plantear
Eta y John Lewandowski...
Por la economía.
Ya, ya, ya, pero...
Ha habido tantas preguntas al respecto
que me parece que...
que había que nombrarlos.
Yo creo que tiene sentido, sobre todo, por la situación
económica del Barça, en los últimos años,
donde dices, oye, es que si me
espero a que Eta y John sean un futbolista
de 80 millones igual no llego.
Pero bueno...
Está diciendo algo interesante en AWL, tío.
Perdón, sí, sí.
Te he venido un bostezo porque estoy cansado, joder.
Qué apuroso, eh.
Aprende de NAO, eh. Aprende de NAO que esto
lo tiene trabajado.
Hay que... Puedes como bloquear la mandíbula.
Sí, lo he intentado antes.
Es que llevo ya tres bloqueadas.
Sí, sí, sí.
Que...
Hombre, que cuando el titular es
oye, cambias el abandono, es que pone Eta y John.
Dices, ostras, cuidado.
Pero creo que tiene sentido
desde el momento en que dices, oye, es mi...
Bueno, una especie de Vitor Roque.
Y yo eso sí que lo veo. Creo que es un
futbolista muy interesante por el que apostar.
Yo soy etista,
además no poder.
Etiano.
No sigáis.
No sigáis, no sigáis.
Soy avioneta, como le llamaba
en ese momento.
No, vamos, yo me lo creo.
Creo que puede ser uno de los mejores delanteros de Europa.
¿Sí? Sí, sí, sí.
A mí me parece un jugador de ese techo.
Me encanta todo lo que hace Eta y John.
Justo. Además, es que yo creo que
se relaciona muy bien con la segunda línea, además.
Creo que es algo que el Barça también necesita de su 9.
O sea, yo creo que sí o sí,
el Barça lo tiene que fichar.
Y que luego sí ve que... Igual está un poco verde.
Dar una pretemporada, que cada vez se estira menos
hacer una pretemporada, pero bueno.
Dejarle un poquito de margen,
ver para qué está.
Y bueno, si no te da intentar fichar a otro.
O fichar a los dos y ceder a Eta y John.
Pero vamos, que tiene que ser un jugador que esté controlado por un equipo enorme.
Sí, yo estoy de acuerdo.
A mí me gusta mucho, me convence mucho.
Necesito verle más como para
ser tan optimista.
Pero claro, el tema es que aquí está
Ferran. Entonces, lo de Eta y John solo
lo encajo. Sí, de verdad,
no puedes fichar nada.
Y haces el Ferran titular,
y no puedes fichar a Eta y John suplente.
Pero de verdad, me parece que no es un
escenario probable. O sea, no sabemos cómo van a
ser las cuentas del Fútbol Club Barcelona.
Pero sí sabemos
que de una forma u otra hay
fichajes más ambiciosos que se han hecho
cada temporada. O sea, luego
ya vemos que si se inscriben
de una manera u otra. Pero se terminan haciendo
los fichajes y se terminan inscribiendo.
Y es que a nivel político, Miguel,
como presidente del Barça, tú no puedes
vender que Eta y John es el instituto de Lewandowski.
Eta, entras en año de elecciones,
que ya se está comentando
en Barcelona que hay una candidatura unitaria.
Entonces, sobre todo por el punto de
es verdad que el mercado de
nueve es muy complejo porque
o haces una apuesta, como la de Eta y John,
de un coste
relativo, o ya
pasas a 100 millones. O sea, el escalón
de los 60-70 es una estafa
para un equipo como el Fútbol Club Barcelona.
Apostar por, no sé,
es que no quiero decir ningún nombre, pero un delante.
No es que ni yo queres, por ejemplo,
que creo que es lo que ha hecho la Asena este mercado.
Y no contempláis la posibilidad
de que Marcus Rashford
siga marcando tantos goles como está marcando
llegue el verano y le llegas al Manchester United.
¿Cuánto? ¿50 kilos?
No, tienes opción de compra.
Rashford sería para mí
lo que es ahora.
El suplente de
Ferran, el suplente de
la FIña o el suplente de la
Barça.
Mi duda es, más allá de
Julián Álvarez, que creo es el nombre que se nos
mira todos a la cabeza pensando en un futuro nuevo para el Barça,
Haaland es el nombre.
Haaland is the name.
Renovó 10 años, en la última renovación
renovó 10 años.
Fue el año pasado, ¿no?
Yo estoy de acuerdo con tu resoplido, Naúl,
pero también es verdad que
Haaland es el nombre.
Porque el Barça ha hecho cosas impensables.
Pero fichar a Haaland
de parece, o acordaros,
lo que dijimos en su día
con razón de aquella reunión
de padre Haaland y Mino Rayola
en Paz Descansé
viajando a Barcelona cuando todavía era jugador del Dortmund.
Claro, si yo lo digo.
¿Cómo se va a meter el Barça en esta pelea?
Se está haciendo unos zorros a nivel económico.
Yo lo digo porque creo que es el anhelo
porque Haaland ya ha expresado que quiere jugar en España
porque la relación entre
Rafael La Pimienta
y Deco Barra La Porta
es muy buena
y porque si tienes el dinero
pues evidentemente tienes que ir.
Y que el tema de los intermediarios
lo domina muy bien el Barça.
El Barça los trabaja muy bien.
Esas operaciones por eso.
Veremos.
Este es un tema que ya afrontaremos poco a poco
intentando ver todas las opciones
sin vender humo
que no es nuestra intención nunca
pero siempre contemplando todas las opciones
porque en el fútbol todo va muy rápido
y pasan muchas cosas que no esperáis meses antes.
Diego RM10
¿Qué techo le veis a Pablo García
tras el Mundial Sub 20?
Creo que en el Mundial Sub 20 ha estado bien
pero no creo que haya recalibrado el techo de Pablo García.
Pero no sé cuál le veis en general.
El techo a mi me parece que si se redefine
como segundo punta
o como delantero
que pueda jugar acompañado de un delantero
un poco más grande y demás
yo creo que tiene un techo muy alto.
Yo como extremo en la élite no termino de ver.
Porque me parece que no es un jugador rápido.
Y creo que ahora mismo el extremo
tiene que ser potente en aceleración
tiene que tener un muy buen dribbling
y una gran salida de ese regate.
Y creo que Pablo García tiene buen dribbling
pero no tiene una salida muy rápida de ese regate.
Y yo creo que es mucho mejor
cerca del área que no pegado a una banda.
Entonces para mi
si se termina definiendo como
un segundo punta
ahí le puedo ver un recorrido más alto.
Gustándome mucho.
Y estando de acuerdo con Alex
que seguramente sus sitios
temas por dentro quedes de la banda
calma.
Quiero seguir viendo a este chico.
Tranquilidad. A mi me cuesta todavía
definir dónde está el techo de Pablo García.
No ha marcado en el Betis todavía.
Tranquilidad.
Que se haga un juego en el Betis.
No, en la Liga no.
En la Liga no.
Me acuerdo de dar el dato yo en...
En la del fútbol.
Puede ser.
Falló el día de Abde.
El día contra la Real Sociedad creo que es.
Que Abde le envía un balón brutal.
Lo falla y no era su gol.
Siendo un jugador que en lo principal
que destaca es que tiene gol para burro.
Ya cuenta alguna vez que pregunté por él
y me dije...
No ha marcado.
Es que este chico empezaba de lateral
pero siempre tenía gol y está obsesionado
con el gol.
De una forma que no lo han visto nunca.
Ha terminado acercándose cada vez más a la área
por eso compro también lo que dice Alex
de que seguramente por sus condiciones
y sus virtudes
todo lo que sea jugar detrás de un punta
le va a venir muy bien.
Pero yo sí que le veo
un poquito más de chispa
en espacio corto.
Creo que va a empezar como extremo.
Pero no le veo...
A ver cómo lo explico.
Es un caso natural para él
acercarle a la portería
porque al final si tienes gol hay que acercarle.
Pero no me parece que
no pueda hacer carrera a la banda.
Creo que... A mí es un jugador que me encanta.
Creo que va a ser un jugador muy importante
en el Betis si aguanta en el Betis.
No le pasa como con Jesús Rodríguez.
Y le veo proyección de ese jugador muy importante.
Me lo creo mucho a Pablo García.
No he terminado de ver
en los momentos en los que sale del regate
que ahí le pillan.
Ahí le pillan.
Y me parece que el extremo actual
lo estamos viendo.
Que no le pillas.
La Mén te deja atrás y no le pillas.
Pero yo estoy acuerdo.
Él no es extremo. Otra cosa es partir desde la banda.
Yo creo que en el fútbol tan rico actual
en el famoso vídeo que hicimos
de las nuevas posiciones
él es el típico futbolista que te encaja
en el pasillo interior.
Es decir,
porque estaba pensando en...
Estaba pensando en Mastantuono.
Mastantuono no es tampoco un extremo.
Pero es un jugador
que si tu ubicas en ese pasillo interior
medio abierto, medio central, puede habilitar el disparo.
Puede tener esa combinación.
Yo creo que eso podría tener sentido.
Con un lateral largo podría tener sentido.
Mira...
La selección sub 20, el otro futbolista junto a Fran González,
el portero del Castilla,
que más destacó fue Janbir Djili.
Pregunta Mario CHR4
por él.
Pregunta Adri si Janbir Djili será capaz de salvar al Mallorca.
¿Es la última bala de Iagova?
A ver...
Se fue al Mundial Sub 20
dejando un ratito muy bueno
ante el Atlético de Madrid.
Dando esa asistencia a Murici en el tanto del empate.
El impacto ahí en ese partido fue muy positivo.
Por perfil,
es un perfil que el Mallorca está
necesitando y lo hace bastante tiempo.
Y me parece un fichaje muy bien tirado en ese sentido.
Tanto como ser la última bala de Iagova,
cargar al chaval con esa responsabilidad
no creo que sea apropiado.
Pero vale que no sea apropiado.
Pero la afición es lo que siente.
Claro, la afición es lo que siente.
Ahora mismo es virgencita virgencita
que Janbir Djili sea lo que parece.
Porque si no es Virgili,
tendrá que ser un entrenador diferente.
Pero con Iagova, no.
Sí, pero para que Virgili saque al Mallorca del descenso
y salve a Iagova en el banquillo,
Virgili se tiene que transformar en la misma mal.
No creo que tanto.
Yo creo que puede marcar un poco la diferencia.
El Mallorca es otro equipo
que tú le ves los partidos
y porque sabes toda la situación que hay fuera.
Pero tampoco está muerto.
Están partidos.
Pero es que nos están preguntando que si no es Virgili.
No es Virgili.
Pero es que nos están preguntando que si es la última bala de Iagova.
Para ser la última bala de Iagova,
tiene que regatrear la banda y marcarla por las cuadras.
Si va a asistir a Murici,
Murici será la última bala de Iagova, no?
Es a lo que voy.
Yo creo que la última bala no.
Porque creo que no, no, no.
No es que tenga...
Yo creo que Iagova no tiene una última bala.
O sea, me parece que tiene varias dentro del cartucho
y creo que este parándeo de selecciones seguramente
ha servido para que se afinen ciertas cosas.
Pero mis sensaciones es que
puede ser eso que agite la coctelera que necesita tanto el Mallorca que la agite.
Eso es.
Es que me parece que es ese futbolista que
se la entregaban el día del Atlético de Madrid
y era ahí te genera otra ventaja.
Y luego se terminan contando el gol.
Porque no era un centro tampoco medido.
Era un remate de Jambirgili que le termina impactando la cabeza a Murici.
Pero yo creo que en esa combinación
Jambirgili y Murici,
el Mallorca va a tener mucho para ganar partidos.
Yo entendía más la pregunta de...
¿Es el jugador que puede hacerle cambiar un partido?
¿Es el jugador que puede hacerle cambiar un poco la dinámica?
Porque creo que Jambirgili tiene eso de
ser un pequeño electro shock.
Desbordar, agitar,
generar optimismo.
Que no le sobra al Mallorca ni al mallorquinismo ahora mismo.
Y poder hacer eso.
No sé si le quedan muchas balas en la recámara a Yagova.
No sé muy bien cómo va a tirar eso.
Pero es verdad que es uno de los equipos
de...
Decíamos antes con el Valencia de Corberán
que no creemos que esté en el mismo punto.
Pero si no remonta,
antes del parón de noviembre hay cambio.
Yo el puesto de Yagova lo veo
más seguro de lo que dicen los resultados.
Creo que tiene esa influencia
en el club.
Y creo que él genera esa sensación de
confianza de la gente que trabaja con él.
Y por ahí se explica con aquel match ball
que salvo con Osasuna en su día.
A partir de aquí, Jambirgili tiene que ser
importantísimo.
Porque aparte de Jan, sólo hay
otros que no van plantilla.
Y como le gusta decir, Alex está a sano.
Tiene que encomendarse a Jambirgili.
El sistema de Yagova necesita de un extremo como él.
Creo que él ha mostrado hasta la altura del reto
en ese ratito que le vimos.
No sé hasta qué punto
uno puede llegar a idealizar
esos 20 minutitos
contra el Atlético de Madrid.
Se idealizan siempre.
No por Virgili, en general.
Sí, porque el equipo está mal.
Y luego de 20 minutos, y de repente se va.
Y estás un mes pensando.
Vaya, 20 minutos hizo Jambirgili.
Pero sí que creo que es un futbolista con nivel
de primera división, para poder tirar del carro.
Y yo me creo a Jambirgili.
Y creo que el Mallorca no está tan mal como parece.
Si esos 20 minutos
los hace
varias veces de aquella temporada,
Jambirgili va al Mundial.
Es decir, es que lo que vimos ante el Atlético de Madrid
es de un extremo súper encalador.
Es que de la subvención lo hizo.
Es una posición que le hizo un poco internacional.
Igual habría que...
Sería importante para la última bala de Iagova
que Nahuel Molina esté en frente de Jambirgili.
Claro, claro.
Pero es que es un show que está en el Barça Athletic.
Es algo que voy.
No sé, parece una responsabilidad muy grande.
Pero Adri,
sin ser exactamente eso,
Jesús Rodríguez el año pasado
para el Betis fue un electroshock.
Luego llega Antonio de Triana y eso no es un electroshock.
Eso es una corriente alternativa.
Pero creo que Jesús
tiene un partido ante la Real Sociedad
en banda derecha, luego pasa a la izquierda.
Es como un primer síntoma de optimismo.
Un primer futbolista que dice, vamos, seguidme.
Y yo creo que eso Jambirgili puede serlo
porque luego tiene jugadores como...
Al Mallorca lo tiene que salvar Rayo,
lo tiene que salvar Darter, lo tiene que salvar Murici.
Son esos futbolistas lo que tienen que salvar.
Y aquí incluiríamos a Dani Rodríguez
si Dani Rodríguez no estuviese apartado.
Son esos jugadores, Maféo, Mógica.
Estos jugadores son los que tienen que salvar Mallorca.
A ver lo de Dani Rodríguez, que parece que aclara un poquito el panorama.
Pues ojalá que aclare, porque eso...
Porque eso será síntoma positivo.
Independientemente de lo que esté bien y lo que esté mal.
No es que han dos preguntas, decía...
La penúltima es la más repetida junto a lo que decía de Tayo y el Barça.
He cogido la de Jorge Gege, pero podría haber cogido...
La de otro.
Es Jorge Gege, pero con G.
Jorge G.
Con el inicio de Elchi y Levante,
No tenéis la sensación de que hay dos grandes incógnitas para el descenso.
Veo inviable que la Real esté ahí y el Girona tiene plantilla para salvarse de sobra.
A quienes veis ahí...
Este es un tema que han preguntado como digo mucha gente,
porque me parece que tiene mucha razón.
Yo veía al principio a Elchi, equipo revelación.
Metí también a la La Veste y creo que con Coudet
transmite unos síntomas de competitividad que dices,
hostia, vale que no va a ser equipo europeo,
pero no le veo sufriendo.
Y claro, luego dice,
el Levante con Carlos Álvarez y el Tayo y el John.
La Real, hay que ver qué pasa,
pero el Girona está creciendo.
No sé hasta qué punto, no sé si hasta conference,
pero está creciendo.
El Sevilla, que podría estar en esas quinielas,
no está con Almeda.
Es otro equipo revelación como Elchi.
El español, que es el último equipo que se salva el año pasado,
no es equipo exactamente revelación,
pero bueno, que está más cerca de lo de arriba que lo de abajo.
Entonces es una pregunta esta
de mucho calado.
De no saber, yo sinceramente no te sabría decir.
Yo no sé si el Girona está en el final,
pero yo entiendo que el Real Oviedo va a estar ahí,
porque creo que
por plantilla actual
y por ver el efecto carrión,
podemos entender que va a estar ahí,
pero yo no veo a Levante
tan rimbombante.
Creo que está
teniendo un buen rendimiento fuera de casa,
que está aprovechando mucho el momento
de Tayo y el momento de Carlos Álvarez,
pero me parece que puede ser equipo
a tenerlo en consideración.
Quizá el Elcheno tanto, pero un poquito más a Levante.
Yo estoy de acuerdo con el Levante,
yo a Levante lo seguiría manteniendo en la ecuación.
Y de hecho al Elche también.
Hay que ir con calma,
porque todas las temporadas son muy largas
y esta temporada lo que tiene pinta
es que, por lo que estamos viendo,
si encima no hay ningún desahuciado,
esto hace que todos igualen más
y que te lleves a 40 puntos la salvación.
Sí, sí, que consigan menos puntos,
porque no tienes ese garantizador
de puntos que era el Valladolid
la temporada pasada.
Viendo...
repasando clasificación
me huele mal, bueno,
me huele muy mal oído, la verdad,
me huele mal.
He cuidado Getafe y Rayo.
Yo Rayo no.
De hecho, fijate.
A ver, es que el Getafe es la pelea del Getafe,
igual que está en la pelea de Álvarez.
A diferencia de otras temporadas,
veo al Getafe mucho peor.
Creo que el Getafe se va a reforzar.
El Getafe se va a reforzar.
O sea, es que no... Vamos.
¿Cómo?
Yo creo que esa reflexión la hemos tenido muchas veces
y la mayoría nos hemos equivocado.
El año pasado lo hizo, claro.
El año pasado fichó seis jugadores.
El año pasado, al final, Terrats.
Cuidado que te he dado un par de victores tres
que son las que te salvan.
Pero seis, no fichó, no.
Si eran los que pedía, abordarás.
Creo que fueron cuatro. Juanmi, Terrats.
Y el lateral, Bernat.
Bernat.
¿Qué tela?
Igual sí, fueron tres.
Claro, eran los que pedía, abordarás.
Que en un primer momento le dijo Ángel Torre.
Bueno, espérate que igual son cero.
Yo estoy convencido que cuando bordarás
dijo seis, dijo firmo tres con sangre.
Pero como diga tres, aquí viene uno.
Pues que este año diga Bernat.
Juanmi, Terrats. Ah, vale.
Y Niom.
Niom ya ha llegado.
No recuerdo a quien es, pero marca un gol
y una asistencia. Sí, Victoria y Vincoliseo.
Creo que es su re-debut, si no me equivoco.
Sí, sí, sí.
Pero Getafe sí que puede estar ahí.
Y Rayo y Celta, cuidado.
Igual que digo que yo me tiraba a Rayo
como decepción, sí que creo que al final
se va a terminar salvando. Pero Rayo y Celta
son esos equipos año,
europeo, año en el que
los ascendidos parece que tienen más argumentos.
El otro día que ganaba
los dos en Europa, ¿no era Europa
generador de buenas dinámicas?
Eso no lo dije yo, eh.
No, no, no.
Lo preguntaste aquí en el Q&A
y aquí algunos dijimos
que Europa normalmente
lo de generar buenas dinámicas tampoco es...
Que a mí me lo parece, eh.
O sea, yo...
Ya acabo de recordar.
Pero si esto lo dijeron, gira el Dice y Nigo, no nosotros.
Sí, sí, bueno, y yo también.
Es porque dice...
No, no, no. Lo digo...
No, no, yo no he cambiado de opinión.
Pero yo estaba ahí cierto, cambiado de opinión
a favor de corriente...
Yo metí al Rayo
equipo de decepción.
Bueno, no lo mandabas a segunda.
No, no. Vale, vale.
Yo me reafirmo
en que a la vez y Girona
yo los veo abajo, que son los que metí.
Vasa mamá.
Los metí junto a...
Elche. Elche.
Elche los metimos los cuatro.
Sí, pero yo creo que dije
que cambiaría el Elche, pero no recuerdo quién dijo.
El Mallorca. Mallorca, bueno.
Y a la vez también.
A la vez lo ves tan mal.
Es que a mí la a la vez, de verdad, creo que le falta
muchísimo talento arriba y creo que se lo va a complicar la vida.
Pues yo creo que está defendiendo muy bien.
El jefe lo vio. Sibera está bien.
A mí me gusta mucho la de arriba.
Está recuperando bien la bola arriba.
Lo vamos a analizar. Con a Carlos Vicente.
El lunes sale análisis
del Deportivo Árabes.
A lo que ves que
en otras temporadas no valía
de revac y ahora parece muy importante.
Kaleve me parece un futbolista
que me deja muy frío.
Pero el equipo funciona.
Sí, sí.
El chacho sistema está hirviendo, ya verás.
Pero las dinámicas coletivas están muy bien
pero llega un momento en que se te cae el equipo
y tiene que tirar el carro alguno.
Y yo con el equipo caído no veo a nadie.
Esto también podemos decir, Nahuel,
hacer la contraria y dices que levantes y netes
en el mes de la Copa África.
Bueno, creo que es un mes.
Pero sí, se puede romper el cruzado
o mañana Carlos salvaré.
Bueno, también.
Y me puedo morir yo mañana también.
No, no.
Porque tienes que ir a la piscina.
A partir de la 1.
Tienes que mediar la ruptura de cruzado de nadie
para decir que no hay que tirar el carro.
Tienes que currar. A partir de la 1, Nahuel.
Pero del viernes.
Claro, claro.
No tienes tres días para resucitar, Nahuel.
Sí, no se puede dejar solos.
Ya lo he visto.
Y la última cuestión de Patau.
Patau.
Patau. Patau for fingers.
A tú.
Esto me huele mal, la verdad.
No sé qué significa pero me huele mal.
Pregunta o plantea.
¿En qué puesto consideráis
que hay más diferencia?
¿Cómo lo dice Nahuel?
Pregunta...
Chachara, ¿no?
Pregunta palique.
Pero mola más chachara.
Un poquito de chachara.
Chachara, chachara.
En qué puesto...
Yo se hubiera nacido en 1967.
¿En qué puesto consideráis
que hay más diferencia hoy en día
entre el considerado topo 1
y el siguiente?
En qué puesto consideráis que hay más diferencia hoy en día
lateral derecho entre
Arraja Kimi y el siguiente
que no concreta.
Yo creo que el año pasado igual fue
Jurskunde pero no lo concreta Patau for fingers.
Patau.
A ver,
tendríamos que trazar el mejor once.
El top 3 de esa...
No, pero mira, descartemos.
Delantero o centro.
Vale, dale.
En el puesto de central.
¿En el puesto de central?
Sí.
Es el que había pensado.
Yo había pensado...
Creo que es un mal momento en general de centrales.
Pues para España no.
Salibá.
Para España, ale normal,
estabas dando palos hace...
Hace nada.
Pero digo Din Haussen.
Pero Din Haussen está lejos.
Kubarzy.
Están lejos.
Yo antes hubiese dicho Kurtua.
Pero este año no.
O sea 2022 igual te digo Kurtua, pero este año no.
Para mí lateral izquierdo.
Nuno Méndez. Hay más diferencia entre
Nuno...
Y Cucurella.
Y Cucurella que entre Van Dyck y Salibá.
Pues...
Yo lateral izquierdo.
Lateral izquierdo.
Más que el derecho.
El derecho tienes el segundo mejor.
Claro, es que yo creo que esa pregunta también te aclara mucho.
Pero exacto.
Si no sabes quién es el mejor,
es que hay mucha diferencia.
Igual.
Sí, probablemente sea Raph.
¿Qué metes a Cundé?
Yo creo que el año pasado fue Cundé.
Carvajal ¿no?
Carvajal, Cundé y Raph.
Claro, pero Carvajal.
Pero quiero decir, en este momento
no podemos mencionar Carvajal.
No, pues yo creo que va a ser Raph.
Sí, va a ser la del lateral derecho.
No sé,
Carvajal ha vuelto bastante bien de la lesión.
Pero...
Pero al nivel de...
Creo que ha vuelto bien,
mejor de lo esperado, estoy de acuerdo.
Pero...
No sé.
Si estuviera bien Vinicius, podríamos decir el extremo izquierdo.
Pero claro, yo creo que no está...
No, Carvajalía.
Sí, bueno, pero igual.
Pero Vinicius 2000.
Vinicius 2000. El mejor Vinicius.
Ahora no. Claro, claro.
Por abrir otros debates.
Claro, en derecha tienes la Mínsala.
En el medio centro.
Bukayo Saka también.
En el medio centro,
a falta de Rodri,
que yo lo metiera como Carvajal en un limbo ahí.
Habría que ver.
Pero bueno, creo que puede haber
jugadores de un perfil parecido.
Si, pero...
interior.
Si, con Vitinha en medio centro, por ejemplo.
Estamos con Vitinha a muerte.
O sea, con Pedria a muerte, pero bueno.
Está Vitinha.
Sí, pues pueden ser los laterales, ¿no?
O...
El derecho, el derecho sobre todo.
Y el extremo derecho entre Jacúb Aminté y el resto.
Porque quién es el mejor portero del mundo.
Yo seguiría...
Es decir, si juego una final, sigo metiendo a Courtois.
Y creo que no está al mismo nivel.
Pero sigo creyendo que es Courtois.
A mí la pregunta...
Por eso digo, hazme la pregunta de...
Juego final de Champions,
¿a quién cojo en cada posición?
Pues yo cojo a Tibo Courtois.
Estamos hablando de Courtois y Donnarumma, ¿no?
Sería un poco...
Sí, sí. El momento sí.
No hay tanta distancia ahora, ¿no?
Por eso, Courtois 2022,
entre el que fuese el segundo en ese momento,
que tendríamos que echarle un vistazo atrás.
Sí que creo que...
Igual fue Bonu.
Pero yo creo que ahora mismo no.
Ahora mismo...
A mí ahora mismo no.
Es un tema interesante.
Yo creo que será el lateral derecho.
Tenemos el lateral derecho,
el lateral izquierdo propuesto por Alex,
el central, que no lo había pensado yo,
pero puede tener su aquel de Adri.
Y ya está, la banda izquierda, si Vinny no está
al máximo nivel, pues no...
Yo creo que la del delantero centro
es lo que planteas si dijesemos entre el top 5 y el resto.
Ya... Sí.
Sí, pero claro, pájaro.
Sí, pero por ejemplo en el lateral derecho,
el quinto mejor lateral derecho del mundo,
su diferencia...
Claro, su diferencia respecto al décimo
no es tanta.
Tú lo que planteas es que igual el quinto delantero
está más cerca del primero que del sexto.
Sí.
Sí, porque hay un salto.
Porque si tú tienes que coger en vape Halan,
y también en el delantero central,
tú tienes que coger en vape Halan,
que es el que más te gusta.
Y por ejemplo,
en cuanto a la de Julian Cain, por ejemplo.
Sí.
En cuanto a rendimiento de ahora, y luego tienes Isak.
Julián.
Y Julián.
La diferencia de Julián con,
me lo invento, Equitique.
Es mayor que respecto a en vape.
Claro. Sí, puede ser.
A ver, esto es una paja increíble.
Eso es Miguel.
Tremendo cipote, ¿no?
Miguel necesita el Pagiator Plus Plus.
¿Sabéis que desde que
utilicé cipote como sinónimo de
problemas o de lío
lo he escuchado mucho?
O sea, que no...
A ver, esto se dice...
Cipote, ¿no?
A mí me pasa que desde que te compraste tu coche lo veo en tal parte.
No, no.
¿Tiene juego?
Es esa cara, no, no.
No, no.
Es que es verdad que...
Es el coche más usado del mundo.
Sí, es un coche muy bien comprado.
Pues hasta aquí.
Ferraré, ¿eh?
Ojalá, no.
¿Qué hiciste en la editorial de los Ferraris y los Porsches?
No, pues...
Un coche familiar.
¿Y no quisiste vosotros vosotros no tener cipote a esto?
Soy yo.
Que tengo un coche de una marca que no voy a revelar.
Bueno, queremos doxear a Miguel Quintana.
Tengo un Sub.
Que creo que es bastante apropiado conmigo.
Bueno, tenemos como 140.000, de hecho.
Hasta aquí este Coanei.
Gracias, Pizarritas.
Y felicidades a Usera Coat.
Usera.
Gracias.